[Musique]
feu vert pour johnson et
l' agence européenne
annoncé hier que le rapport bénéfice
risques liés à l'injection du vaccin
reste positif
comme pour astrazeneca dans - des
difficultés pour convaincre malgré tous
nos citoyens sur l'astra zeneca fille
est une problématique à laquelle là on
doit collectivement réfléchir en termes
de communication et de capacité à
convaincre les résultats de la stratégie
qu'à son bien au delà de plein de
vaccins qui sont aujourd'hui disponibles
et ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
les experts encore une fois je m'élève
paochinda conditions mais j'ai confiance
dans la médecine française
être député ça n'est pas fait pour les
jours normaux l'achat macro nist qui se
dit crevé à un an de la fin de son
mandat comme lui beaucoup de marcheurs
pensait pouvoir tout révolutionner à
leur arrivée à l'assemblée nationale en
mais certains d'entre nous se sont
retrouvés à seulement appuyer sur un
bouton pour voter les lois grenelle un
député qui a finalement quitté les rangs
macro nist comme une trentaine d'autres
depuis le début du mandat
si je parle de ces armes c'est que nous
ne pouvons nous passer d'aucune les
vaccins astrazeneca le vaccin johnson
and johnson comme le vaccin father comme
le vaccin moderna comme tous les vaccins
qui reçoivent une autorisation des
agences de santé indépendante au niveau
européen et au niveau français sont des
vaccins qui sont sûrs et efficaces ce
retour à la vie d'avant l'exécutif le
prépare d'abord sur les déplacements à
partir du lundi 3 mai les déplacements
de plus de 10 kilomètres et donc inter
régionaux devraient être de nouveau
autorisée en revanche sur le couvre feu
l'exécutif réfléchit à le maintenir en
l'état ou à l'aménager pour le chef
d'accusation violences volontaires ayant
entraîné la mort
nous déclarons l'accusé coupable à
l'annoncé du verdict les supporters de
georges floyd ont laissé exploser leur
joie à minneapolis où se tenait le
procès mais aussi dans d'autres villes
américaines
quand le verdict tombe la soeur de jake
floyd installé à houston explose de joie
la voix cassée par l'émotion elle se
confie sur voir direction a menotté
sortir de ce palais de justice comme mon
frère a été menotté de l'asmo pour moi
qu'il n'a plus en plus tard on change le
monde d'ici à ce coin de rue tous
conscient d'assister à une page
d'histoire tous soulagés également et
nous devons faire plus pour qu'une telle
tragédie ne se reproduise pas
c'est le moment pour notre pays de se
rassembler de s'unir en tant
qu'américains il ne doit jamais y avoir
de refuge pour la haine en amérique ni
et sachant qu'il serait probablement
conduit en prison à l'énoncé du verdict
chauvine avait écrit le numéro de son
avocat sur sa main gauche
autre temps fort de la journée les
échanges téléphoniques entre la famille
de georges fleuve joe biden et kamal
harris
aujourd'hui nous sommes soulagés mais
cela n'enlève rien au chagrin car là une
mesure de justice
ce n'est pas la même chose qu'une
justice équitable pour tous et ce
verdict nous en rapproche chaque mais il
ya encore beaucoup à faire
lorsque j'étais enfant on disait ce qui
se passe aux états unis arrive un an
plus tard en france aujourd'hui ce qui
se passe aux etats unis
il arrive 20 secondes plus tard en
france et je crois que ce n'est pas
évidemment ce qu'on peut souhaiter de
mieux à notre pays que d'enclencher une
spirale qui ressemblerait à celle des
états unis en la matière et ge a radié
de la police derek chauvine encourt
jusqu'à 40 ans de prison
il connaîtra sa peine d'ici deux mois
son avocat n'a pas réagi après sa
condamnation
ce verdict fait passer le message à sa
famille qu'il était quelqu'un que sa vie
comptait que toutes nos vies compte et
c'est important
c'est sûrement son plus triste
anniversaire la reine elizabeth ii
célèbre aujourd'hui ses 95 ans sans
celui qu'elle surnommait sa force son
époux le prince philip